Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I have to say we haven’t had a simulation paper in
a while so today’s episode is going to be my way
of medicating myself. You are more
than welcome to watch the process.
And this paper is about performing collision
detection. You see, when we write a simple
space game, detecting whether a collision has
happened or not is a mostly trivial endeavor.
However, now, instead, let’s look
at the kind of simulation complexity
that you are expecting from a Two Minute Papers
video…first, let’s try to screw this bolt in
using an industry standard simulation
system, and it is…stuck. Hm…why?
Because here, we would need to simulate in
detail, not only whether two things collide,
they collide all the time, but, we need to check
for and simulate friction too! Let’s see what this
new simulation method does with the same scene.
And…oh yes! This one isn’t screwing with us and
does the job perfectly. Excellent. However, this
was not nearly the most complex thing it can do.
Let’s try some crazy geometry, with
crazy movements and tons of friction.
There we go. This one will do. Welcome
to the expanding lock box experiment. So,
what is this? Look, as we turn the key,
the locking pins retract, and the bottom
is now allowed to fall. This scene contains
tens to hundreds of thousands of contacts,
and yet, it still works perfectly. Beautiful.
I love this one because with this simulation,
we can test intricate mechanisms for robotics and
more before committing to manufacturing anything.
And, unlike with previous methods, we don’t need
to worry whether the simulation is correct or not,
and we can be sure that if we 3D print this,
it will behave exactly this way. So good!
Also, here come some of my favorite
experiments from the paper.
For instance, it can also simulate a
piston attached to a rotating disk, or,
smooth motion on one wheel, leading to
intermittent motion on the other one.
And, if you feel the urge to build a
virtual bike, do not worry for a second,
because your chain and sprocket mechanisms
will work exactly as you expect to. Loving it.
Now, interestingly, look here. The time step size
used with the new technique is a hundred times
bigger, which is great, we can advance the time
in bigger pieces when computing the simulation.
That is good news indeed. However, every time we
do so, we still have to compute a great deal more.
The resulting computation time is still at least
a hundred times slower than previous methods.
However, those methods don’t count, at least
not on these scenes, because they have produced
incorrect results. Look at it some other way -
this is the fastest simulator that actually works.
Still, it is not that slow. The one
with the intermittent motion takes
less than a second per time step, which
likely means a few seconds per frame,
while the bolt screwing scene is likely in the
minutes per frame domain. Very impressive! And,
if you are a seasoned Fellow Scholar, you
know what’s coming, this is where we invoke
the First Law Of Papers, which says that research
is a process. Do not look at where we are,
look at where we will be two more papers down the
line. And two more papers down the line, I am sure
even the more complex simulations will be done
in a matter of seconds. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!